[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 hoy jueves nos acompaña como
todas las mañanas a Marta Moya Marta
bienvenida bueno guerra por acá
nuevamente empezamos hoy como avanzamos
en nuestros titulares nuestra
introducción del programa con una
exclusiva del periódico estadounidense
Washington que avanza que Estados Unidos
podría estar cada vez más cerca de
iniciar un deshielo económico con
Venezuela hacia Raúl buenos días el Wall
Street journal publica esta exclusiva
que titula Estados Unidos Busca aliviar
las sanciones contra Venezuela lo que
permitiría a Chevron a esta empresa
petrolera extraer petróleo en ese país
el acuerdo propuesto requeriría a
Caracas por parte de Estados Unidos que
reiniciara las conversaciones y los
diálogos con la oposición para
garantizar elecciones libres en 2024 las
conversaciones discretas se han venido
realizando a partir del mes de marzo
destaca este periódico pero se
empezaron a partir de la última semana
cuando Venezuela liberó a seis
ciudadanos estadounidenses y a un
residente permanente estadounidense que
estaban encarcelados en Venezuela y por
su parte Estados Unidos liberó a dos
presos que estaban allí sobrinos de la
primera dama de cilia flores y que
habían sido condenados por narcotráfico
esta reducción de las sanciones y está
reanudación de las extracciones
petroleras podría suponer una posible
reapertura para Estados Unidos y para
Europa a las expectaciones de petróleo
de Venezuela las conversaciones entre el
gobierno de Joe biden Nicolás maduro y
parte de la oposición venezolana se
habrían desarrollado también para
liberar cientos de millones de dólares
que estaban bueno congelados en bancos
de Estados Unidos para pagar
importaciones de alimentos medicinas y
equipos para subsanar la red eléctrica y
de agua Venezuela en la década de los 90
pues extraía cerca de 3,2 millones de
barriles de petróleo al día pero después
el sistema colapso por la corrupción las
sanciones y la poca inversión entonces
Bueno pues estas sanciones y estas esta
reanudación de las conversaciones se dan
además en un momento de alza de precios
de los combustibles y cuando la OPEP ha
dicho que reducirá la producción de
barriles y esto ha enfadado mucho a
Washington y porque Venezuela porque
Estados Unidos necesita de Venezuela en
cuestión del petróleo Marta Así es
cambiamos el tema pero seguimos con la
prensa estadounidense porque el New York
Times publicó un informe que cita a
fuentes de la inteligencia de ese país
que sostienen en Ucrania que estuvo
detrás del asesinato de una mujer muy
cercana a las esferas del kremliner
relatábamos Aquí también nuestro
noticieros en su momento Así es hablamos
de daria dubina la hija de Alexander
duguin el ideólogo de Vladimir Putin y
titula el New York Times que Estados
Unidos piensa considera se bueno
refiriéndose a las agencias de
inteligencia que los ucranianos podrían
estar detrás del asesinato de esta mujer
que vemos fue en el mes de agosto A las
afueras de Moscú y pues falleció en un
atentado con un coche bomba las agencias
estadounidenses sostienen que partes del
gobierno de Ucrania no citan a todo el
ejecutivo de kiev Podrían haber
autorizado este atentado del cual dicen
Estados Unidos no participó además bueno
se destaca en esta publicación del New
York Times que Ucrania ya negó en su
momento los bueno que estuviera
implicado en este atentado y lo volvió a
negar después de las investigaciones de
la inteligencia estadounidense la
inteligencia de Estados Unidos está de
alguna manera alineada con la agencia de
inteligencia nacional rusa el fsb que
también culpó a Ucrania de estar detrás
de este atentado sin embargo pues la
inteligencia rusa dijo que los
ucranianos contrataron a una mujer para
que fuera a Rusia y después esta mujer
se había alquilado en un apartamento de
área duggina perpetró o sea planeó el
atentado lo perpetró y luego huyó de
Rusia además sostiene este artículo que
Estados Unidos no dio detalles de quién
en el gobierno de kiev podría pues haber
dado esta orden y ni siquiera así O sea
Perdón podría estar al tanto de este
operativo Estados Unidos sostiene este
informe del New York Times es la
frustrado por la poca transparencia de
Ucrania respecto a sus planes de guerra
Aunque sostiene que las relaciones y la
inteligencia las conversaciones entre
los dos países han mejorado los últimos
meses porque
Ucrania le informó a Estados Unidos de
la contraofensiva que ha liderado kiev
este mes de septiembre Marta como
siempre Muchísimas gracias por toda la
información mañana viernes con nuestra
última revista de prensa de la semana
mañana